thank you maurice yes i'm here with
alexander grishou who just
finished his game against nvla sasha
first of all welcome
to romania welcome to bucharest and
welcome to the show
and thank you uh it's a pleasure first
of all to interview you i know you are a
such a legend
but first take us through the game no
but there is nothing to discuss is just
four strokes more or less were you
surprised by
mvl's uh opening choice or absolutely
not no of course i was surprised he
plays grunfeld very rarely
what do you think about this choice of
his he's been playing grunfeld pretty
much his whole life
he tried it a little bit in rapid games
during some of
the other tours also during candace he
played grunfeld what do you think about
this strategy
yeah i mean it's a bit funny that there
are two
players at the very top with completely
similar
repertoires uh him maxim and
jan both plays
exclusively greenfield and neither for
their whole lives yeah it's
a bit strange you know coincidence
would you say uh is somewhat similar
as to your um tendency to go into time
trouble let's say
it's within your element and the
groomfeld is within his element would
you
be able to make that comparison not
really i mean this
this is an opinion but also both of them
try to play fast you know both are very
good tacticians
so yeah it's i mean it's a bit funny
that there are two
extremely similar players because
you if you take others then there are
differences
yeah between each of them yeah like
let's say you take magnus and caruana
okay they're
different in some ways you take caruana
and wesley they are different you take
nakamura and wesley they're different
but those two are the most
similar players at the top did you have
any surprises prepared for uh him in
this game or no no it's just a draw yeah
i just did the research i uh in my last
10 maybe first round games i
i think maybe made four draws and lost
six
so i thought draw is better than losing
so this was planned all along well thank
you very much sasha
and we're looking forward to see you
next time